the audience that's good welcome
everyone welcome to Berlin again thanks
so much for being here today I mean
there's so many awesome talks happening
in parallel so I'm really happy that you
decided to be here with me or maybe you
wanted to go to the pandas workshop but
you ended up here by accident because
the rooms were messed up
well now you're stuck it's really cool
to be among the first people to speak at
this conference it's also a huge
responsibility to have a good start and
I'm gonna talk about graphs today so I
wanted to start off with a joke but for
me that did Network
well three people got the joke that's
that's fine for me that's all I'm asking
for one second seems like I got there we
go alright but what is this actually
about today like in short it like I want
to tell you that analyzing graph data is
really really cool and it's getting more
and more important but once you have
larger networks making sense out of them
is getting really really hard so what we
will learn today is how to visualize
interactive graph networks in Python and
we will do it on an example and in fact
we will analyze the skill sets of data
scientists and how these skills like
relates to each other in a larger
network and the text deck it's Python
it's Network X trait let's I pi widgets
and plotly so and this is basically how
the result will look like have like a
little bit of hover you have like the
possibility to just lay out that
recalculate stuff you can filter some
some nodes you can make you can put them
more nodes then you can obviously remove
edges and you can at the end
search and find nodes in your graph this
is basically what we will talk about
today so Who am I and why am I talking
about this my name is Yann I'm a data
scientist at in stuff oh and stuff for
is the star
in Heidelberg and we deal with
automating the recruiting process and
we're trying to make it as fair as
possible relating to the first talk
today we're not using supervised
learning so we don't have the problem of
introducing bias to our data which makes
this entire thing much more ethically
correct and I'm also an organizer of PI
data as we dressed which includes
Mannheim Cal's WHO and Heidelberg and
obviously I live in this very pretty
city Heidelberg so if you have questions
about my employer the company I work for
please approach me personally or send me
an e-mail to my work address if you have
questions about PI data in the region
that I'm from if you want to speak
attend sponsor anything I mean many of
you might have cool talks just let me
know either in person or through my
personal email so before we dive deep
just a little refresher on graph
networks so we're all on the same page a
graph obviously consists of nodes and
edges and edges connect usually a pair
of nodes nodes can be all kind of things
they can be people computers documents
anything really and they can have what I
call arbitrary meta data so for example
in this case you can see the node it's a
user on Facebook he's 25 years old and
he has 240 friends and through this edge
he's connected to a different person and
as I said I just described how nodes are
connected can be you are friends with
you are connected with or a scientific
paper is cited by another scientific
paper and what is important to know is
that edges can be undirected or directed
weighted or unweighted directed and
undirected when two people are friends
on Facebook that is undirected because
it is mutual when you follow somebody on
Twitter that is directed obviously
because it's one-sided and you can say
that every Edge has the same way it so
it's like a binary and edges present or
it's absent or edges can have like their
own weight you're like much more friends
with this person than you are with this
other person for example so why is
interactive graph analysis importance
and before I start please raise your
hand if you have seen speaker mining
reverse engineering of Spiegel Online
before
nice so for those of you who haven't I
really really recommend watching this
talk it's by David kriezel he's a really
cool investigative data scientist and he
scraped
spiegel the journal for many many years
and he did all kinds of interesting
analysis with with the content that he
received and I will show you the result
of his of his research in a second but
what I'm trying to tell you is that with
small graphs you can produce like a
static image and it's fine and you can
look at it and it's it's pretty but the
bigger the graph the more information
you as an analyst also need to process
and the more difficult it gets and from
my personal point of view once you have
more than hundred or some hundred nodes
and edges in your graph it becomes
almost unfeasible to really comprehend
what's what's going on there's just
information overload it's it's
overwhelming so what I'm talking about
here for example is again David's talk
what he did is he rendered a graph with
tags that spiegel associate to their
articles so attack might be like finance
cleazor or it might be a refugees or
something and they they looked at how
these text appear together in articles
and he rendered a network and the
network looked like this so you can you
can barely see it but you can see some
colored pixels every colored pixel is
like a node he had like seven thousand
nodes at the end and several thousand
edges it's impossible to analyze this
picture as it is static graph analysis
visual graph analysis is it makes no
sense here so you need interactivity and
to be fair
David had some interactivity in his plot
he had the ability to zoom in and zoom
out which was key but I believe you can
do more than that you can do more than
just zooming in and zooming out
especially when you have so much data
and such a big graph present so what was
my personal goal
I wanted to develop a proof of concept
for a self-service interactive analytics
tool for graph networks that runs in
Jupiter because I like Jupiter that is
easy to build and maintain for a data
scientist who probably doesn't
necessarily have like an academic
training and software engineering
processes medium-sized graphs reasonably
fast like some hundred nodes and edges
shouldn't be a problem and looks all
right doesn't need to be super pretty
but it needs to have some nice
aesthetics and regarding the inter
interactivity that I imagined at the
beginning when I was doodling this on
like a piece of paper I really wanted to
zoom in and out obviously I wanted to
get additional information when hovering
over certain elements I wanted to be
able to filter for nodes and edges I
wanted to search for nodes and I wanted
to update the graphs layout on the fly
which we will talk about in a second so
as David's cool data set with the
Spiegel tags is not available as far as
I'm concerned I had to come up with my
own data set and this is also when my
company comes back into place what we
will deal with today is skills that
every data scientist should have so
basically if the data set set composed
by us
it contains the 250 most common skills
for data scientists their relative count
in percentages of all users having that
skill and the similarity between each
pair of skills so 250 squared basically
so if we're thinking about it we're
dealing with a weighted graph where the
weight of the edge is the similarity but
it's undirected because similarities are
always mutual and to give you a certain
understanding of how this data looks
like I wanted to give you the least
scientific most silly way of presenting
data the word cloud and you can see some
cool stuff in there obviously big data
is
very big and very often used machine
learning AI data signs data mining
tableau Hadoop big data analytics steep
learning there's there's many things on
this graph it ranges from data
engineering to classical data mining to
deep learning you name it it's basically
all in there and all kinds of cool
Python frameworks in there as well as we
will see so I had the data I had a goal
what I needed next was what I call the
master plan so I wanted to build an
interactive network visualization and I
wanted to put it on top of four pillars
visuals so basically what the user will
see the information that I will convey
to the user then network algorithms
things like for example calculating the
positions of individual nodes in a graph
user input the ability for a user to
specify filters search boxes etc by
themselves and the underlying model
logic so if I press this button this
should happen and then this should
update and then something should appear
in the front end so these were my two
four pillars and then I looked for the
corresponding packages frameworks to
make this work and to me it was a rather
easy choice for visuals
I chose plotly for the network
algorithms
I chose Network X for the user input I
used I pi widgets and for the underlying
module logic and model logic
I used trade --let's and I will talk
about all of these four packages briefly
so let's start with plot Lee plot V is
probably the one that is the most
questionable in this set because there's
many many many choices when it comes to
visualizing stuff in Python even
visualizing interactive stuff in Python
to name one that is actually supported
by numb focus there would be bookie or
bouquet that is also a very very cool
tool why did I use plot Lee first of all
for those of you who don't know plot Lee
is an interactive open source and
browser-based graphing library for
python and it also exists for
and JavaScript the mind the main reason
why I used it is because it had a new
major release this year the version for
which like arrived in July and now it
comes with a quite nice grammar of
graphic likes API similar to ggplot in
our that works really well with pandas
dataframes and I just wanted I was
curious I just wanted to try it out so I
decided to go for plotly and not for any
of the other existing tools so if you
want to see how it looks like you
basically import plotly you have a data
frame for certain columns and all you
can do is you say I want to plot a bar
chart on this data frame on the x-axis I
want that column and on the y-axis I
want the other column and you get this
so in three lines of code you get a
rather interactive web-based
visualization so very convenient Network
acts again there was not many things to
choose from it's a Python package for
the creation manipulation and study of
the structure dynamics and functions of
complex networks and it also has a new
release this year that version 2.3 and
basically what I need this for is to
calculate the layout the positioning of
my notes because in my case my notes
they didn't come with a natural position
like an x and y coordinate that you
might have when you work with geo data
in my case I had to calculate the
position the coordinate of every note
based on how they are connected to other
notes and that's called a note or a
graph layouting algorithm so again
basically it's very simple only a few
lines of code you initialize a graph you
add a couple of notes and a couple of
edges and then you just run an existing
layouting algorithm on top of the graph
and what it returns is a dictionary idea
of the node and then the X and the y
coordinates so that's a very convenient
format to use further down the road
trade --let's was something that I
introduced I explore
during my research for this for this
project it's a framework that lets
Python classes have attributes with type
checking dynamically calculate the fault
values and unchanged callbacks it's also
in version 4 and the latest release was
just this month and it's part of the
ipython universe so what this means is
you can have a class and this class has
a class attribute number or num num
which is an integer you can use the
decorators to tell this class to
validate every change that I attempt to
put on this attribute and here for
example I'm validating that the new
value for num needs to be greater than
zero otherwise it's throwing an error
and I'm also telling you that every time
it's changing it should print like a log
message basically and these two methods
I don't have to add any logic they are
executed automatically whenever this
attribute num is trying to change so
here you can see an example and it's
like establishing an example object I'm
setting num to 1 and automatically it's
printing a message numpce neuro to 1 I
didn't have to trigger this this is
triggered completely automatically and
when I'm trying to set it to negative 1
I automatically get an error message num
must be positive so this is nice this
way of dynamically triggering methods
updating other attributes based on how
things change make your logic in the
backends much more much simpler and then
the last component of my master plan I
pi widgets it's an interactive HTML
widget for Jupiter notebooks and the
ipython kernel is already in version 7
so there has been quite a lot of major
releases for this package and again it
also has a very very nice easy API in
this case I'm establishing an integer
slider with values between 0 and 10
steps of 1 and the default value of 7
and once I execute this in a Jupiter
notebook I immediately get a very nice
HTML widget that I can drag and play
with very very very easily so these were
all the four components that I need it
and I started working on it that was
like okay I have my data if my master
plan let's start working on it and at
some point I looked at my code I was
like oh my god this is really really
awful code whatwhat is going on like I
had this one monolith class with like
the the front and div defined and the
backend logic and the network algorithms
and everything was there I was like this
is a mess I cannot show this in front of
people I was getting a little nervous I
was like I need to I need to do some
research and I had to confront myself
with possibly my worst fear most data
scientists worst nightmare software
architecture design patterns and I was
like how do you actually write software
and one thing I came across in AI pi
widgets tutorial was how to build these
kind of dashboards using model view
controller which was something I hadn't
used since my bachelor and so the more
complicated master plan looked a little
bit like this I had different views I
had a view for the figure which is the
actual graph I had a view for how people
can like define layouts I had a view for
how people can filter notes and edges I
had a view for how people can select and
find individual notes on the other side
I had models model said took certain
inputs calculated certain things on the
fly using trade lists and then I
basically had a controller that linked
everything together and I wanted to make
it as nice as possible but still I
realized I mean you see all those red
arrows that it's not only going like
nicely horizontally left and right
sometimes I had to like use like a
shortcut where it goes right down into
another model and and trigger something
else again data scientists are usually
not trained software engineers sometimes
that's a problem but the result was a
little bit clunky but working nicely
separated modular implementation where
for example you could test all the
feature
using the model classes without having
to touch or change the views or anything
so it's it's a nice separation and now
we go to the live demo what could
possibly go wrong with a live demo so I
just want to show you like the code
basically in my case it's very simple I
have can you guys see this well
otherwise I'll zoom in a little bit I
have a class which I call Network
analyzer before that I import nodes and
edges that I have prepared I can show
them to you again so the nodes look a
little bit like this you have an ID
advanced analytics you have a size again
it's a relative count which means that
the largest node has a size of 1 and all
others have a value between 0 and 1 so I
can again like for example say sort
values sending false and you can see
uh-oh it's it's not a serious nevermind
there we go here you can see the the
biggest nodes let's maybe put down the
top 10 I mean you've all have a good
understanding because of the word cloud
of course but here's some more
information so you can see Big Data
machine learning our data analysis SAS
artificial intelligence it's all there
and now maybe let's look at the edges
quickly that's a great question
let's let's move questions to the QA but
I will definitely answer that one edges
basically has a very similar layout so I
can say sort values but by weights and
ascending equals false so for example
here matplotlib and Seabourn high torque
and Saffiano lasagna has a weight of 1
just heads up we have a normalization
script that does reasonably well
normalizing skills but some people are
so crazy when it comes to stating their
skills that it's really difficult for us
to normalize everything so we have some
funny funny looking skills here but the
majority looks pretty alright and for
example the the similarity between pi
torch and clixsense was the lowest in
the entire entire dataset so that I
believe makes perfect sense so but now
we have to zoom out a little bit so you
can see the entire graph that's
basically how it looks like you have the
network here with a couple of nodes and
edges you can hover over the nodes you
get the coordinates emphasize you have a
nice color bar that also tells you a
little bit more but now for example I
want to use more nodes so I hover I go
into the filter tab here and I say I
want to have all nodes and I hope I
don't break my system now because it's
not as efficient as I think it would be
and it's calculating older there we go
you see it's fast as hell and that's how
it looks like when I present all the
nodes that are bigger than 1% of the
relative count but now I have too many
edges so I say well yeah it's 2 like
this it looks better and I could
technically do things like adjusting the
layout I could use different kinds of
layouting algorithms when I choose
something like spectral like you see it
adjusts very very quickly and but now
let's go a little bit deeper into the
analysis I will focus like on only a few
edges and one nice thing to see is that
here for example you have caressed
neural networks panda scikit-learn like
the entire like Python frameworks are
very really close to each other they're
building like a little island above here
tensorflow it's connected by everything
through machine learning which is the
bigger node which is spreading in all
directions if we go from the left we see
big data analytics data visualization
big data analysis data analytics so the
more pragmatic staff in data science
down here we have tableau we have click
we have ETL data ingre integration etc
power bi SAS and data warehousing and
here on the right
have AI and concision silligans the main
insight that I wanted to share with you
from this graph is that Quincy Quincy
Liggins is possibly the furthest away
from deep learning and neural networks
which is because everybody's using it
but it doesn't have like strong patterns
with the actual skills that it takes to
work in artificial intelligence it's
actually similar to big data that is
also not in the ETL data warehousing
area and yeah like the last thing I can
show you is I can do things like this
and I can say where is the AI node and I
get navigated there right away so this
is something you can build very quickly
it was a little bit of a hustle at the
beginning but now it's in a nice
structure and easily and maintainable so
let's wrap it up what is the outlook of
this what I don't like yet is that when
in portly you zoom in into a scatter
plot the scatter doesn't increase
relative to the zoom so they stay the
same which is mind-blowing to me why
would this be the default behavior so
you could avoid this using like circle
layouts and stuff but it would be would
put him off some more implementation
right now the my logic for rendering the
figure is very dumb every time I make a
change it discards all traces and then
it has to re-render everything obviously
would be clever
only to render the Delta so that the new
edges or remove the old edges etc which
would make this entire visualization
much faster and more responsive the node
information should be updates that you
might want to see there's some other
stuff than the XY coordinates and edges
should also display information right
now they're just dumb lines that you
cannot hover over anything that would be
cool if they could highlight the notes
that they are connecting and stuff like
that I have a couple of ideas and while
building this I was introduced to panel
which is another framework for building
dashboards there's also - from plotly so
there's also other tools to consider for
building the entire frame rather than
trailers and ipad widgets maybe I will
do an evaluation of that some good
resources for you there's really cool
tutorials by plotly on how to visualize
Network graphs and how to visual how to
use widgets but not together this is why
I'm using this though I'm doing this
and there's a really nice three-hour
workshop on Jupiter widgets by Sylvia
Colleen one of the main contributors to
Jupiter and this is where I found this
part with the model view controller in
notebook 903 that's it my time is over I
think I made it just in time thank you
so much for being here I hope this was
somehow insightful for you I'm up for
some questions and thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah we'll just repeat it for the
recording so why was Python not
mentioned there I was I was so surprised
but I just couldn't find Python among
the 250 most similar skills to data
science one thing is that the data said
that were using it is not from 2019 it's
a little older it's not from 2005 or
something but it's like from 2016 Python
was already well established back then
but that's why for example R is still
extremely prevalent in the data set and
also we noticed that Python in our data
set has very strong ties to a more
classical software engineering so two
things like Django it has it has strong
ties to C++ it has strong ties to Java
and it doesn't but the funny thing is at
the end the Python frameworks are still
displayed so Python seems also to be a
very generic skill that people put on
their profile all the time it's like
when people put Java on their profile
and you know they're lying because they
haven't used Java in 15 years but they
still put it there Python is similar to
that so that's why the patterns that we
can observe are not as strong as for
other skills
so the question is what's the bottleneck
calculating the layout or visualizing
the traces so they did the graphical
components of the graph from what I
could see on this network and you have
to consider it's 250 nodes but it's
fully connected so every node has a
connection to every other node and using
things like a spring layout or a
chimeric Hawaii layout on reasonable
parameters goes very quickly unless you
exaggerate with the number of iterations
it goes very quickly which is very very
nice the problem right now is partly
because it's a little slow with
calculating the traces so I think the
biggest improvement in terms of speed
would be only calculating the new traces
rather than recalculating everything but
then again this accounts only for this
particular notebook graph and I would
have to see how this scales for example
if you have 1,000 nodes or a hundred
thousand edges probably then calculating
the network becomes exponentially or
quadratically more expensive so the
comment was that if you want to go like
full control you should use d3 which is
JavaScript only and you're absolutely
right as a data scientist I give it my
best to avoid any kind of JavaScript and
rather find hacky solutions that only
involve Python for example for the for
the width of the edges that something
plotly cannot do with the portly Express
but you can hack it a little bit by
calculating individual traces for
individual edges because then again you
cannot assign an attribute to the edge
width but you can just loop through all
edges and just set the edge width
statically it works quite well but then
again it's it's slow and but for such
thing I would probably team up with with
a front-end expert that could help me
with this but yeah definitely great
comment thank you
[Applause]